[Music]
now maybe a villain at heart but that
doesn't make her a bad person being
chosen to go to auradon prep really
changed her for the better
coincidentally it also fueled the Isle
of the lost rebellion now and her
friends are about to face their biggest
challenge yet and we can't wait to see
what the outcome is in the meantime
let's take a look at how much mal has
evolved since we first met her
malla is easily one of the best
descendants characters ever she's smart
brave and everything we'd won in a ruler
unfortunately for her she was born on
the wrong side of the tracks or in her
case on the wrong side of the ocean
being the daughter of the almighty
Maleficent is a tough act to follow but
when we first meet mal she's determined
to make her mother proud problem is
there's no pleasing Maleficent so as a
result mal is used to letting people
down and going back on her word
at first glance Mouse a mean girl who
loves to cause chaos she devises evil
plans and torments those who get in her
way
in fact she's got quite the reputation
on the Isle of the Lost
Mao was raised to detest beautiful
surroundings and enjoyed the uglier
things in life we're not kidding
she literally steals candy from a baby
right before our eyes to make her mother
proud mal pushes people away and keeps a
sour look on her face at all times but
deep down mal can't help but wonder
about the finer things life has to offer
the young villain spent so much time
living in her mother's shadow that she's
dying to become her own person and
luckily for her she's about to be given
the opportunity to do just that
living on the Isle of the Lost
isn't exactly fun but it's the only
thing that mal knows so when Maleficent
reveals that Mao Jay Evie and Carlos
have been chosen to attend auradon prep
she's definitely a little excited but
you wouldn't know this by looking at her
she is ice-cold here's where things
start getting a little complicated for
mal Maleficent tasks the V Ches with
stealing the fairy godmothers wand who
happens to be the headmistress at
auradon prep
although the request sounds simple
enough it's actually super risky because
well if mal feels she and the other V
Ches will be sent back to the Isle of
the lost for good but what mouths most
worried about is letting her mother down
this is this
specially true since Maleficent trusted
her with her spell book which is a
pretty big deal
now desperately wants to be regarded as
pure evil problem is she's not as time
goes by
mouths allegiances start to change
especially when she starts falling for
Ben she's hit with a full-on dilemma to
be evil for it to be good
on one hand being evil will make her mom
proud but on the other hand being good
will make mal happy and here's where
things start to change for our favorite
little witch when we first meet mal were
immediately taken back by her rebellious
look she looks like a total villain
which is very fitting but as the movie
progresses she starts to lose a bit of
her edge in the first Descendants film
mouse hair is dark purple with subtle
hints of pink in it it falls to her
collarbone in a cool wave and looks
totally awesome
she's predominantly dressed in dark
purple which is her mother's favorite
color however there are hints of pink in
her leather jacket which is pretty funny
considering that she dislikes the colour
Mouse pants are ripped in lined with
leather studs decorate her outfit from
head to toe and a few shades of toxic
green can be spotted all in all Mouse
outfit is totally wicked however by the
end of the movie mouths look completely
changes she's seen wearing a lilac gown
to Ben's coronation and she looks like a
total princess this light shade of
purple foreshadows Mouse character
change mal is finally embracing the good
side of things and wearing light colors
for the first time ever however she's
still dressed in purple proving that she
still has her mother's mission on the
brain but one thing at a time right mal
experiences a huge change of heart at
the end of the first descendants film
and Ben has to do a lot with that
when mal first met then she didn't
really care for him in fact she slipped
him a love potion so that he would ask
her to the coronation ball you see the
fairy godmothers wand was going to be at
the ceremony and Mau wanted to be in the
arms reach of it however when mal
realizes that Ben is truly in love with
her she chooses to follow her heart
instead of her mother's orders this is
the first time
now makes a decision for herself without
her mother overseeing it so it's a
pretty huge deal now chooses to be happy
and good revealing that she wants to
live in Oregon
permanently however Maleficent soon
comes to face her only child in a
terrifying stare off luckily mal is
quick to use a spell turning Maleficent
into a tiny lizard Mao defies the odds
and chooses to be herself this
revelation brings her instant happiness
and she gets a dose of what a real
happily ever after feels like but her
story's not over yet
mouths first transformation was
revolutionary still it's nothing
compared to how much she changed in
descendants too
[Music]
descendants juice starts off with the
brilliant performance ways to be wicked
in this musical number we see them out
we know and love however it soon becomes
clear that everything that is happening
on the screen is actually happening in
Mouse head malice daydreaming of the way
things used to be before she moved to
auradon prep she snaps back to reality
to reveal that she's no longer the
villain we remember her mal is doing her
best to smile at the camera and she's
looking the part
but her perfect exterior starts to crack
when she later sees herself appear on
the TV screen the highly anticipated
cotillion is on its way and mal seems
pretty nervous about it this isn't the
cool calm and collected mal were used to
it's obvious that she's trying to be
someone she's not and it's a little
disheartening well being fitted for her
dress mal walks over to her spell book
and she starts using magic problem is
using magic is sort of frowned upon at
auradon prep regardless mal is on a
mission to become the perfect lady
so she enchants herself to memorize a
book titled lady manners
what's going on with our favorite
villain now might have chosen to become
a good guy
but she was raised by an evil sorceress
on a castaway island mouths roots
haven't disappeared simply because she's
about to become an official lady of the
court and she finds herself thinking
about the past more often than she'd
like to admit it's obvious that mal is
trying too hard to fit in which is
making her feel like the odd one out
there are some things that mal can't let
go of though for one she's still using
her mother's spell book despite Evie's
request to donate it to a museum
personally as your best friend I
strongly believe it belongs in the
museum along with my mirror all in all
mouths roots are still planted in the
Isle of the Lost
and the V case seems to be a little
homesick to make matters worse then is
mr. perfect and he never slips up so mal
is desperately trying to do the same
after all now the new allegiance is
making headlines and the exposure is
hard for her to deal with whereas Ben
grew up under the public eye now grew up
tormenting children and seniors
light from the outside mouths life seems
to be a fairy tale but once you take a
step closer you realize that something
wicked is brewing in her soul we're so
used to seeing Mel and her classic
leather outfits and dyed hair that we
were stunned by her new look in
descendants - mal is seen wearing whites
yellows and lace which is super out of
character and to top it all off her hair
is platinum blonde however subtle hints
of purple remain at the tips proving
that she's in there somewhere
after using magic and getting busted mal
and Ben get into a big fight and in
Mao's mind the fight is the cherry on
top of a big preppy milkshake
now goes back to her dorm puts on a new
DK suit and makes the choice to return
to the Isle of the Lost
it's here that dizzy helps mal return to
her roots by giving a fresh new look by
the end of the makeover it's the auradon
inspired mal is nowhere to be found
dizzy dies Mouse hair a purplish pink
and she gives her straight across bangs
and a much-needed haircut mouths new
look is simply gorgeous to top it all
off mal is wearing one of Evie's newest
designs unlike before Mouse outfit is
more pink than purple and it has
splashes of vibrant green strewn across
it now looks better than ever and thanks
to dizzy she's ready to take on the
world the Isle of the Lost is exactly
how Mau remembers it problem is its
inhabitants are even less welcoming than
they were before now finds out that
she's considered a traitor by the vks
which is a little too much to bear it's
then revealed that Ouma is the big bad
of the sequel and she's not going down
without a fight
but more on that later for now let's
focus on how much Mouse character has
changed from the first movie to the next
in descendants Maus struggled to be evil
because her heart wasn't in it in
descendants - however mal is neglecting
her villainous side and trying to be
perfect like Ben the social expectations
that were Don is placing on mal are
suffocating to her and she's yearning to
go back to what she knows
luckily for a mouse she's got amazing
friends and a boyfriend who loves her
for who she really is not who she's
pretending to be by the end of
descendants du mal
is that she doesn't have to choose
between being good or evil because well
she can be both this coming-of-age
moment really allows mal to be yourself
which is something that magic spell
could accomplish keep watching to find
out how Mouse transformation affected
her magical abilities fairy godmother
that's me thank you this belongs in the
exam
mal is becoming her very own person and
we're loving it fans are patiently
waiting for the third descendants movie
to be released but there's no official
release date just yet the Disney Channel
kept us busy with the short story under
the sea an action-packed teaser trailer
actors dub Cameron is reprising her role
as mal however this should be the last
installment the franchise receives that
is unless Disney wants to go at it again
with a brand new cast
but according to mal the story isn't
over yet last time we checked uma was
still trying to break free from the Isle
of the Lost
and she had an entire pirate crew on her
side the evil sea which is clearly up to
no good but according to the trailer
there's another villain in town Hades is
bringing his wrath to the descendants
threequel and things are about to get
ugly the god of the underworld seems to
be posing as Mao's father and fans are
going wild with theories on top of that
Ben's ex-girlfriend is rumoured to be
working with dr. facili a princess
Audrey obviously has it out for mal
because well she did steal her boyfriend
and all Huma Hades Audrey and dr.
phacelia are coming for mouth and her
pals but do they stand a chance against
Maleficent's daughter we don't think so
after all now it's proven to be a lot
more powerful than she knows much like
her personality and fashion style mouths
magical abilities have evolved from one
movie to the next by now we all know
that mal is an excellent driver a
talented graffiti artist and a ruthless
fighter
however there's so much more to her than
meets the eye I think it's time that
girlfriend much like her mother mal has
the ability to cast spells and brew
potions in descendants mouths powers are
mediocre however she manages to turn
Maleficent into a lizard by the end of
the film and let's face it that's not an
easy thing to do
now spells improve come descendants to
but the most notable transformation that
occurs is her turning in a full-blown
dragon this shocking scene had us
catching our jaws before they hit the
floor as a matter of fact even now
didn't know that she was capable of
altering her fizz
Cole shaved it's clear that mouse power
is influenced by her emotions the most
powerful one being loved mouse heart is
growing in size and so are her abilities
we can't wait to see what new powers
she'll discover come descendants three
mouths new look is beyond drastic and
we're totally in love with it
although d3 is still a while away we've
got plenty of fashion propaganda to go
on this outfit reveals what we suspected
mal has finally become her own person
despite not being on good speaking terms
with her mother mal is still repping her
colors she's grown out her bangs and
dyed her hair a vibrant purple in fact
it looks like mal ditched the color pink
altogether
mouths new outfit is practical and
stylish it's definitely what a warrior
would want to wear to battle and since a
huge war is on its way this look is
super fitting Mel's decked out in
leather and her outfit is pretty
futuristic she's wearing green combat
boots and a cropped leather jacket with
cuts in the sleeves
we've never seen her look this wicked
here's a sneak peek at mouths newest
gown isn't it breathtaking the
asymmetrical dress is inspired by Mouse
shape-shifting abilities there's a pink
dragon strewn across a purple background
that is hemmed in green mouths even
sporting some dragon wings on her back
this look yells I'm a BK and I'm proud
of it it's nice seeing now feeling
comfortable in her own skin what do you
guys think about her transformation now
spent most of her life hiding her
feelings and following her mother's
orders but that all changed when Ben
decided to allow for V case to attend
auradon prep despite being the Beauty
and the Beast son then immediately fell
in love with Maleficent's daughter this
adorable love at first sight moment was
definitely one-sided though luckily for
Ben mal eventually realized how amazing
love could be she chose to be good
instead of bad however she later
realized that she didn't have to choose
between the two she could just be who
she wanted to be mouths come a long way
and she wants to help other vks do the
same we've learned so much about mouth
throughout the first two films however
one burning question remains who is
Mao's father and
why is she so powerful Mao was told that
her father was human however this seems
to be a lie
considering how dominant her magics are
in fact she might even be stronger than
Maleficent herself but Mommy Dearest
probably doesn't want to know that Mao's
a natural-born leader who would make an
amazing Queen so we can't wait to see
what she and Ben get up to once the
score is settled so are you guys excited
to see Mao's evolution reach its final
stage because we sure are let us know
which descendants character you want us
to cover next in the comments below
feeling wicked give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things we
post new videos every day so hit that
notification bell to stay up to date
with the latest descendants news thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]